Personality research consistently shows, that different personalities prefer
different careers and college majors. In fact, college counseling centers often
administer one personality questionnaire When trying to guide students, we are
still searching for a career that fits them. That questionnaire is Myers-Briggs
type indicator, or the MBTI for short. The MBTI consists of opposing
personality types. Extraversion and intraversion. Thinking and feeling.
Intuition and sensing. In judging and perceiving. In other words people are
classified, either as an extrovert or an introvert. Or as a thinker or as a
feeler, and so on. For example, intuition and sensing describes how people
prefer to take in information, focused on what is real and actual. So sensing.
Or on patterns and meanings and data. So intuition. Whereas thinking and
feeling describes how people prefer to make decisions based on logical analysis
to thinking, or prefer making decisions guided by the concern for the emotional
impact it has on others. So feeling. Now, personality types are different than
forms of dimensions because they categorize people as either one type or the
other. Rather than on the continuum from high to low, like we see with the big
five. Researchers using the MBTI have found that extraverts prefers social and
enterprising major such as physiology or social work even elementary education.
Whereas thinking types prefer realistic and investigative majors such as,
mechanical engineering or archaeology. Feeling types prefer artistic and social
majors such as art, music or theater.